In Syria, the UN says tens of thousands have fled the latest Russian-backed...
...government offensives, with most leaving the area south of Aleppo.
In Germany, Chancellor Angela Merkel tells Israel's Prime Minister...
...that all sides need to make a contribution towards de-escalation...
...of Middle East violence.
In Slovenia, bad weather and border closures...
...add to the plight of thousands of migrants in the Balkans.
In the UK, Britain and China sign business deals worth billions...
...as President Xi Jinping meets with Prime Minister David Cameron...
...as part of a state visit.
And finally from the US, Vice President Joe Biden announces...
...he will not run for the White House in 2016.